while there isn't yet another book
between the ballad of song birds and
snakes and The Hunger Games the creative
team behind the movies has ideas about
where a sequel could go and who it would
focus on Nina Jacobson told people I
would love to see Snow's rise to power
because he's just a great character but
it's tiger and understanding how this
girl who loves him so and cares for him
and becomes a woman that we saw in
mocking jay that I'm really fascinated
by until snow decided I wasn't pretty
enough anymore that idea has the backing
of actress Hunter schaer who portrayed
Tigress in The Ballad of song birds and
snakes she told Entertainment Weekly I
want to know what happens even if I
wasn't playing her I want to know how we
get there